[Music]
[Applause]
I don't either but they let me drive it
isn't that weird hey guys
wait how that makes no sense yeah I
don't
have we're back we're back hey guys
welcome back we're domestic terrorists
the to all the gentlemen we are all
domestic terrorists to all the haters
that said leftovers can't go two weeks
in a row we did like what three weeks
even through coid and then and then I I
had to go to me Mexico then your dumb
ass went to Mexico and no streamed I did
I did stream from Mexico I had to go to
Mexico for my family um and uh you know
I I went to Cabo we we stayed at a
resort but uh you stayed at a resort
during the strike what strike the riter
strike do you think that's appropriate
what what are they are they working at
the Mexico Resort um
yeah I P yeah I pulled a bill Mah um but
yeah I something happened to me that
apparently happened to you as well yeah
I I I Ste foot in the Cabo airport and I
got uh I got detained I got detained by
the Customs and Border of Patrol of
Mexico uh they they looked they took one
look at me I had the big Pelican case
with my electronic equipment and they're
like come here and I go over there and
he's like hit this button go he made he
they didn't even make me hit the button
yeah he goes hit this button I'm like oh
what what do you mean he's like if the
light lights up you got to go to the
X-ray machine I'm like I look my
name is Hassan okay I have traveled to
and from the United States of America I
know those shits are not random
do you understand like I always get
random ID checked um even though I have
clear or I always will have like
additional dare you um how dare you
accuse them of not being honest with the
button I for myself I think it is random
I've never been
selected yeah and my experience is
random yeah exactly but uh I always get
selected like when I'm coming into
America they always pull me to the side
and the second selection is so annoying
because they do it right as you board on
the plane I don't know if you know this
right as you board on the plane they
will pull you to the side and go oh
sorry you got randomly uh you know you
it shows on the records that we have to
randomly search you
and like cuz when you're about the board
the plan you're like all right I made it
like this is the final checkpoint like
you're not supposed to be stopped
walking on the like like literally ramp
before you get on the ramp in between
you know where they're like touching
like when they're when they're clicking
on your boarding pass yeah but yeah past
that or there at that point yeah they
just stop you there and they're like we
have to do one more search sorry um
which is fine it's whatever it's an
inconvenience but I'm used to it I just
didn't know that it would happen in
Mexico cuzz spiritually Mexicans
flexican and Turks are the same but they
didn't profile you they just profiled
you for being rich yeah exactly they
profile me for being a rich Gringo uh
instead so yeah they they Shake You Down
100% so tell me how much they get from
you um whatever 19% I so like tax thing
right the same thing to me yeah
like 20% of uh of $1,000 and they looked
up the most expensive they didn't look
it up oh they didn't even look it up no
so what did they get you on so they hit
the button and and then they were
like you have uh you know I go through
the XR machine they're like you have
Electronics you have Electronics in here
and I'm like yeah all the yeah people
travel with electronic like my personal
equipment and I had seen the pamphlet
where it says like you have to declare
if you have electronic equipment that's
like you know there's certain boundaries
certain parameters right why do they
have this because there's a tax why do
they have this tax because
people buy cheap electronics in America
and come into Mexico and sell cheap
electronics in Mexico right but I'm not
a Electronics salesman and the
things that I had in my bag were were
like they were I had monitors I had my
um I had my my
microphone like they're all out of the
box you know what I mean they're like
neatly with the whole ass like little
Studio like yeah this dude's setting up
shop down in Tana so so they they were
like oh these electronic equipment like
that's very expensive I'm like no it's
not you're like no that's $11,000 oh
they just made it up was probably more
than that huh I don't think it was more
than that because it's one secondhand
and two it's like two shitty monitors
like they were specifically pointing to
the monitors like that's $1,000 I'm like
no it's not I have a laptop it says all
of this is allowed like all of the
electronic equipment that I have the
same thing I looked up the law right in
front of them so they pull me they're
like you got to come with us they pull
me to the other room okay they sit me
down and my mom is like panicking let me
ask you this is when you arrive in
Mexico yeah okay yeah so my mom is
panicking I'm texting her I take a photo
I'm like I'm here I'm like at the like a
Customs and Border thing like I don't
know what the going on they see
me take a photo they freak the out
they're like get up right now like they
like literally lose their minds they're
like you can't take a photo you can't
take a photo he like pulls me outside he
makes me read this sign why you
take a over there that they print it out
okay and then they like used tape like
they duck tape to the wall like this
unofficial sign that says it's illegal
take photos inside of like the
detainment center uh and and that like
fines that I might have to pay could be
up to
$116,000 American nice and also prison
hell and and he's like I'm going to
I'm going to put you in jail
like you have to delete that photo right
now so I'm like okay fine dude I'll
delete the photo chill the
out okay calm down and I delete the
photo he's like delete it from your
recently deleted I'm like oh these
know what they're doing
recently deleted yeah they're like go to
your recently deleted I'm like holy
this guy's definitely done this before
oh yeah so I deleted from my recently
deleted okay so they sit me down again
and they're like it's $11,000 you have
$1,000 of uh equipment I'm going to take
your passport I'm not going to give it
back to you if you don't pay this oh
well that wait can he do that no yeah
they didn't threaten that to me no
first all like at that point I was like
wait I was like I'm an American citizen
I don't think he can do that yeah um so
he was like I'm going to take your
passport I might but it's Mexico yeah
mean who knows doesn't matter
bro come on you that's like one call to
the Embassy I know but they'll your
whole week up yeah for sure which is I
don't want to do that and then just let
you go home after like torturing you for
a week yeah well then not like literal
torture but putting you in exactly like
annoying yeah um so I didn't want to
deal with all that
obviously um and uh I'm like it's not
$1,000 so at that point I'm like all
right I'll pay this but like I'm going
to I'm going to try to haggle with this
guy cuz it's not
$1,000 and he's like prove it I'm like
okay and I pull my phone out he goes put
your phone back in your pocket
I'm like well how am I going to prove it
he's like you should have thought about
that before you came in
Mexico and he was like he wouldn't let
me pull my phone out to show him the
receipt of like how much these
electronic equipment cost and so uh yeah
I I had to pay uh this arbitrary fee
that they made up in their mind yeah wow
you had the cash on you no the credit
card payment oh no I well I I was not I
had I had cash on me but I was not going
to give those cash I was
like yeah if you want do credit card
yeah charge back yeah I did not charge
back because charge back Mexican
government um I did not charge back
because I didn't want to like
around you know what I mean put that
well now that you're back what if I go
back and they're they're arrest warrant
so since it happened to me I haven't
been back so it happened to you in a
fashion I used to vacation in Mexico all
the time I love Mexico it's so close
it's beautiful the Mexican people are
wonderful except the ones that work at
UH pass uh you know uh yeah Customs
that's got to be one of the best jobs in
Mexico those guys probably just clear so
much daero dude that is a good
job uh I think like being a federali is
pretty solid uh like local police are
are pretty corrupt as far as I
understand depending on where you are
right so I went in there with a uh D DGI
the Drone oh yeah they told yeah they
were like you have a drone in there I
was like no so I was I checked it on
Just for no reason we went down there it
was it was a few years ago and we just
wanted to get some fun shots for for
YouTube right uhhuh and um the minute we
arrived my drone was on the you know the
conveyor going in and they just like you
they pulled us aside and was like you
can't bring Electronics in to Mexico I
was like the I was like since what
are you talking about like everyone's
walking in with a phone that's just the
same cost as the he's like listen dude
here's the deal we have to charge you
sales tax and I was
like he's like that or you can just get
on a plane and leave I said what if I
don't want to pay it he says you can
leave we won't let you in the
country so I was like okay he's like so
this thing costs like $5,000 I was like
no he let me look it up on the pH oh
yeah M mine did not let me look it up oh
my God if I had to paid tax on $5,000 I
would have been throwing hands at that
point I would have been like you
well you paid tax on almost that much at
a th000 you at ,000 but at that point
like obviously it's not you paid a th000
I paid uh taxes on $11,000 worth of
electronics oh so you paid only a few
hundred couple hundred come on but it's
not the it's not the money it's not the
Mone a thousand I know it's not the
money it's 100% the principal because
like I I'm Turkish I go to Turkey all
the time okay are used to I
don't anymore but like I know how that
works okay I know I know you like
over the foreigners I get it you
know there's a there's a you know the
dollar is very valuable like but in that
situation because I'm not Mexican
because I don't speak Spanish I had no
recourse in that situation in that
moment like in Turkey if they tried to
pull that on me i' be like I'm a
Turkish citizen shut the up I speak
in Turkish and be like no you um in
Mexico I'm not fully
uh you know I don't know how how things
work that well but I know I was getting
over but the principle of the
matter is what frustrates me and it's
nothing for me sure I'll pay that tax
who cares right but there are so many
other people that they could over
that that would genuinely ruin their
entire trip like that's like $200 you
know what I mean that's that's a decent
amount they got way more than that out
of me and I haven't been back since and
I think it was in Cabo or PTO Viera or
one of these hot tourist cities
and I'm really confused by the by the
way that they just allow this level of
corruption to go on where they're just
harassing tourists because I have not
been back since then and I used to go
there like twice twice a year pretty
much yeah um because I I I hated this
feeling of like I'm 100% at this
unhinged psycho's whim to do whatever he
wants with me and um I don't like the
feeling so I'm just not coming back I
don't trust it I don't trust what
they're doing there it just feels
Lawless I mean for me like I don't have
any like tropical weather or or any of
that like nature I don't like any of
that anyway so like I was just
there simply for my family um but yeah
but yeah I I I would say like don't
bring Electronics to Mexico they'll
your whole life up it's just like if if
I were to if I were to ever go back I
think I would go with like a a Handler
you know what I mean like someone both
with a Mexican attorney like no there's
like someone that yeah someone that
knows that would be awesome someone that
knows what's up someone that will like
handle all that stuff ahead of time cuz
like I will always travel with uh at
least like some level of filming
equipment and stuff and it's not like
severe it's a webcam and a
laptop guys you know what I mean before
you freak out over it um and I don't
want it I don't want that to happen
again it was really annoying um speaking
of
handlers um Olivia's handling that ka's
getting she not going to behind the
wall is she she'll be fine I hope not
yeah she'll be okay no she'll be yeah I
just I do get afraid that she every time
she goes behind there so huge when did
you get so big she got she's getting
bigger and bigger you're massive I I
made a miscalculation I thought she was
7 months old now but she was born on
March 5th so she's actually 6 months old
only oh Bo 6 months you look like a full
grown ass yeah she's like almost 70 lb
how much bigger is she going to get
that's crazy probably like 100 plus oh
my God holy
crazy bigger than that when we play and
like sometimes she just like jumps and
pushes me while we're like you know
horsing around and if I'm not planted it
will like catch me off if it catches me
off guard like she could push me yeah I
mean she's huge yeah well there that is
um I still beat her ass
though one last so we have all kinds of
fun things today we have um let's see oh
Eminem put the kibos on ramas Swami Lose
Yourself that's a shame I did I I saw
Len boerd is a drunken God she's such a
trashy I don't know love this story so
much but the let's see the the main ones
is the bite impeachment we've got the um
deranged police cam video which I've
been wanting to watch Mike pillow
deposition oh yeah that I saw that one
and I thought of you immediately I was
like you're going to love this one we've
got the UFO experts in Mexico which
everybody's buzzing about huge huge huge
Revelations here for the UFO
community and
uh other fun stuff like that but before
that I do want to say that right now uh
very quickly here guys at the top of our
show right
now fresh.com at this very moment there
is a sale live now now right now last
chance we're doing a clearance sale on
some of our old
styles uh that are just kind of in weird
sizes and stuff so you're going to be
finding heavy heavy deep discounts on
some of your favorite pieces you might
want to run over now see see if the size
is there see if the the style is there
that you like chances are you're going
to find something I I have those cross
stitch pleated trousers sick which ones
the cross you end these yeah those are
fire there you go so there's 28 and 30
available
those are pretty those are pretty slim
fits my pants who's even a 26 I guess
women yeah 26 that's really that's a
skinny boy right there man 26 I was
in Middle School I think when I had a 26
I've never haded 26 waist in my en I
think like I was born with not a 26
waist 26 what's your waist size right
now uh
38 that's not bad for a guy your size
yeah I mean it's not great I I want to
go back down to I want to give we can
work on that I'm working down to look at
this guy gets skinny all of a sudden
he's like like light bat shaming me a
little bit I think I think I might be um
I think I might be a 38 again yeah I um
at my at my slimmest I was a 34 34 yeah
that was when I was like that's when I
had a sixpack though tight yeah
it yeah it was the best yeah but so go
ahead check it out Teddy fr.com it's
right here on the homepage it's the last
chance it's
clearing right right now get on it Mr
is one keeping helping hunk of a
man did you guys see that TW uh tweet
from like that random like Democrat
account that that said that like I
Tucker Carlson and it had like 38,000
likes and the
fs uh like Henry Winkler was like
responding to it and stuff like people
took it
seriously yeah wait okay I'm looking for
that they used an okay buddy meme uh my
my like meme Community okay bu on on
Reddit um they had made like this fake
video of Tucker Carlson talking about
how sexy I am which you just used right
the sound bite this yeah called to
activism look at that look how many
likes that has that's the guy I had
sex with 24,000 it's 24,000 likes
question if we were giving some
interesting information about Tucker
Carlson should we release it right and
then go down and then the first video is
like uh him talking about Don Lemon
Spirit of easing tension temperature
it's seen on a bit we have no but that
video is irrelevant and then this one
was made by one of my like editors as a
joke over this last 4th of July weekend
and what not but a private and we're
going to go out tonight by singing your
retinas with a photograph of that event
Mr is one heaping helping hunk of
a man close that's the guy I had sex
with that's the guy I had sex with oh
God Henry hry Winkler no is this
really
yes bro that's nuts dude The Fawns what
a legend the fa thinks I had gay sex
with t car that's awesome it's crazy
like dude you were great and Barry
he was he was yeah the first time that
video was posted it was um what's the
other lib guy like the old uh the the
old gay Asian actor guy he George yeah
George oh my yeah George te thought it
was real that
is that is that your George DK I don't
know what he sounds like it's pretty oh
my who is that Hassan perer yeah he
thought it was real too I don't know
what's happening he's been on Howard
Stern a lot he's like a total degenerate
like oh really in terms he's like his
sense of humor he's so funny he's like a
dis he's funny and self Weare but he's
like a disgusting creep do you have a
nice Oh my he must have a huge one
dry oat
mu Howard St funny Howard Stern
Hillary's bravest soldier that's right
that's right I listened to that
interview I thought it was I thought it
was pretty good to be honest yeah cuz
you guys are both Libs he's he is such
like I mean I'm glad he hasn't done like
the bill Mah shift no he's not he'll
never do that yeah but he is definitely
like he's definitely very libbed up like
he's libed up out of his mind yeah it's
good I like it he hates
Bernie uh I don't think he hates Bernie
all right whatever let's move on let's
talk about some yeah um we didn't
even talk about Starfield but Starfield
is fun yeah I have criticisms of it wait
I want to hear what your criticisms are
my criticisms is that one the fast
travel system is so pointless and dumb
so bad I mean it's like why do I need to
jump to another star to jump to another
star that whole mechanism makes no sense
yeah they're like oh you don't have
enough fuel to go to the star but if you
go to the star next to it then you'll
magically have fuel makes no s it's just
t for no reason the is dog the
inventory structure is awful the UI is
really bad carry that much and I'm fully
I'm four out of four on the on the
weightlifting you know yeah and so um
the other thing is like the space travel
aspect of the game which which I was
expecting to be the most fun and Inter
interesting is actually the least
interesting and the most tedious and not
least fun part of the game yeah which is
like dumb as hell man that should be way
more fun yeah especially because the
ship Builder if you get into it is
incredible yeah like the amount of
detail that they put into like ship
building the lore behind like each
individual manufacturer company like all
aspects of that are so they are so
all-encompassing so immersive and then
for some weird reason you know oh is she
eating what is she eating
oh no kle what are you chilling you
crazy no no it's okay what you got
Olivia's running around trying to keep
up with K uh is it I don't think she has
it anymore what the hecking dog you
think it's fine you want to look it's
probably fine it's probably fine fine
she's a big girl she she's a big she can
eat anything she can eat anything and
and survive a goat I just don't want her
to chew on the cables because she is
sometimes a bit of a cord cutter you
know
Zoomer what is it what was
it oh it's just a
l what what the where did that come
from wait yeah where the you even
find that the wait that's mine oh
sto that from me uh it's Cam's we should
have figured s was about to let it
happen cam I'm sorry no I'm sorry that
she got through it thank you um she has
a she has a chew toy like I brought a
bully stick for her in the in the bag if
you want to give it to her give $200 but
like I feel like you know they really
dropped the ball in terms of like
traveling to into planets traveling from
planets it's just they yada yed the best
parts and that sucks I think the main
mission is underwhelming as always
classic Bethesda it's like not that good
in comparison to the side stories that
are awesome faction quests are
incredible uh you and I both have
completed uh one of my favorite ones the
Crimson Fleet one that was such a banger
um main story is pretty boring it's
always the same you're the chosen one
you know save the plan what difficulty
are you playing on normal so I'm on hard
and I find the game to be kind of easy
well it's just like they're bullet
spongy that's it right run out of
bullets yeah yeah but the enemy the
enemies are super easy yeah they're not
they're not very hard to kill I was
thinking of moving it up to very hard I
heard that like it just they don't get
smarter they just get more bullet spongy
yeah yeah which can be annoying I don't
want to do that that's why I play on
normal because I care about the story I
don't care about like it being difficult
I feel like I'm I don't know I got this
one pistol that's like so op it shoots
like four bullets at once and I just one
shot everybody oh Keel huler yeah is it
red like a redol legendary one yeah dude
it's crazy right just one shots
everybody yeah there's well the end at
the end of the at the end of the Crimson
Fleet One you get the the rifle that
shit's nuts yeah but the pistol's better
it does more damage actually yeah um
there's there's a lot of I mean I don't
know it's a good game I I'm I like not
enough weapons you're in space man like
the the potential for Weaponry is
Limitless and then you get what a pistol
and rifle are you I like that
though I like the ballistic weapons well
fine but I like the sound of it I like
the the gunfights that's fine but let's
get more we're in space we're traveling
between Stars you're giving me a rifle
yeah stop it I I don't mind that I like
there's not enough guns though I do
agree with that viable weapons that
you've both named yeah what you know
what you should have in space what
Mech me Mexican checkpoint no Mech power
armor oh Mech yeah there was the game is
missing so and then that's another thing
no cars which is
annoying I did the quest line for um the
Rangers and the quest line ends this
isn't a spoiler and a old Mech Factory
yeah I expected the final boss to be in
a Mech that'd be sick that' be sick he's
not in a Mech he's just some
dude with a rifle that I kill easily
such a joke dude like they just they got
to step it up man yeah but where's the
Mac Bethesda needs to uh
Bethesda needs to definitely improve uh
their their style I mean there's a lot
of great there's a lot of greatness in
the game it's yeah it's better than most
games it's fun it's worth playing it's
not immersive or as beautiful I would
say as like
rdr2 it's not as like alive of a world
as red dead in my opinion Skyrim is
vastly superior game I don't I don't
know if I would say uh there's so many
different ways to play Skyrim there's so
many different builds there's you know
there it's way more open like genuinely
open you're right about that there's not
there's not enough versatility in like
uh builds like I saw a video of someone
playing stealth build which was actually
really cool and really interesting but
that's the only other like the stealth's
a joke in that game like they spot you
in a second for no reason they I think
you need to get like one of those
backpacks that makes you invisible I'm
not doing that yeah um and also I don't
need to go still I one shot everybody on
hard yeah your sucks but that's I'm
only playing it cuz there's nothing else
well there's a lot of games coming out
the Cyber Punk DLC is coming out good um
there is uh the the life of pie game
coming out or Liza pie the the the
Pinocchio game the Pinocchio game like I
might play that it's it's Bas literally
it's a bloodborne the poly Shore one but
that would be awesome somebody needs to
make a mod to put his voice in lies of
PE no it's like a bloodborne uh clone
but it's like you're playing like badass
is that a liced badass murdering pin I
think Pinocchio is a public domain oh it
is it is a very I think it's a very
faithful bloodborne clone too I have
some issues with combat mechanics but it
was I played the demo very good oh okay
are you playing on your steam
deck uh yeah which was I am too did you
it was unbearable to play on the steam
DEA first because like uh you know when
you go into towns it's like impossible
cities are impossible to play in pretty
much it's not that bad but I mean I have
it on the lowest of everything yeah same
I did uh
dude boot it up on your computer yeah
and then do Remote Play which has other
wa what yeah you can remote play off of
your computer it's insane
what yeah it's it's like what's the Ping
no ping it's off of your
Wi-Fi yeah what I didn't know one the
big that's one of the big features on it
yeah yeah I didn't know that either the
only issue is that remote play is also
uh kind of janky and like randomly your
audio will go out and there's no way to
fix it until you like turn off your
steam deck turn it on again Cho like
that even yeah so you just have your
you're basically just streaming from
your computer yeah I run on my computer
and then I'm like upstairs in my bed
playing and the graphics are awesome
yeah it's not as good as like the PC
graphics obviously but like the It
doesn't eat that much battery like just
to stream it and uh loading times are
like nothing towns you can just like
walk around easily my problem is it's a
little choppy essentially it gets really
choppy in cities and computer no no no
no that's what I'm saying so if it got
rid of that I'd be happy yeah it's it it
it kind kind of ruined for me now I
can't play straight off the steam deck
now cuz like now I'm so used to like
playing on the steam Deck with like no
load times whatsoever what the the
loading screens are really annoying too
there's so many for no reason there's
like eight loading screens you load you
load to fly outside the planet then cuz
there's nothing to do outside the planet
then you got to land on the planet then
when you land on the planet go into the
like armor shop and you load into the
tiny armor shop makes no goddamn
sense then you go into a building you go
into somebody's office you load the
office yeah you know what I think the
reason for that is I think the reason
why they made that is because of like
the in unimaginable physics engine that
they have I think that's part of the
reason probably cuz like every single
thing that you can pick up is literally
a fully threedimensional object that you
can manipulate that interacts with you
care if you drop like a pack of
eggs and it rolls I agree I agree with
you which is why I'm saying like because
they hyper focused on the hyper realism
on that front on the physics engine I
feel like they uh couldn't create like
seamless transitions from room to room
and there's always like a black screen
or a loading uh screen every time you
move from one environment to the next
yeah that being Graphics look cool yeah
well I've been playing on my steam deck
they look like yeah the UI IM the
fact that there's no travel options when
you're on a planet is really bad planets
are are AI generated and they're
boring it's always the same you you land
on a planet you click on the planet you
land on the planet you scan the
resources and then it's fun once you run
400 m in the direction of wherever the
you need to go yeah and then you
get the you either get your power or you
go into the same abandoned mine or the
same like facility yeah and it's like
all the assets are identical and for
what basically nothing every time you
know I I explored one planet and then I
I haven't done it since and you would
think that would be a big part of it
like if you go look at Skyrim walking
aimlessly across the map is is you know
great you never know what you're going
to find but in this game it's not the
same it's just a bunch of it's very uh
frustrating it's very annoying the the
way they like kind of dro the ball on
that I mean I know that it's like not an
easy task it's not an easy feat whatever
they oversold it they're like we've been
working on for 9 years okay you never
know what you're going to get which is
ironic though cuz everyone was
on IGN for giving it a seven and I feel
like I think it's a seven I think seven
was such a fair assessment like I I
think it's an eight because maybe it's
an eight yeah because like I love I'm
such a sucker we're Boomers though if
Skyrim's a 10 in my opinion it is I mean
that game is come on you really going to
say about Skyrim no no I I love
dude I've been a I've been a Bethesda
fantasy's Morin he's old head I love I
love all the uh alth the games all the
fallouts I loved see I'm not I think the
the Elder Scroll series is is far
superior to the new fallouts I'm kind of
over that format like I played Fallout 4
and I was like and I beat it all the way
and I'm like I think I'm over this
I don't know like one other aspect of it
I I know that like there's no aliens
obviously spoiler alert except for like
the the Zeno biology or whatever bro I
didn't know there's aliens well I know
there's Critters no there's like
Critters oh yeah what I
mean um my point is like I feel like if
you wanted to make it more like Skyrim
you could have done different alien uh
like forms like Mass Effect here's what
they should have done instead of having
like hundreds of planets that are empty
and useless they should have had like
five star systems or less let's say even
three star systems where each planet and
moon was you know designed pushed out
yeah youel and you're like oh I'm going
to explore you know this moon on this
planet cuz there's going to be something
good there and then when you went and
then when you went to it like um space
travel is kind of boring it's like not
comparable to you know riding on a horse
in Skyrim obviously cuz it's like dark
and black and there's nothing going on
you can literally not even travel anym
but what you could do in that situation
is like make jumps like portals in
between like uh I don't know you could
do like checkpoints in between so like
you go to that checkpoint you still have
the fashion travel option if you want
but you should be able to physically
travel to an area in between uh long
distances where there's like additional
Quest like a bar like a space bar or
maybe like a space Casino you know what
I mean 100% man like they how cool would
it be if you could actually drive you
just go into hyperspace you can go in
and out you're controlling your ship you
can actually fly to other stars yeah
they have they have all of that that's
the that's the problem is that like the
the ship
engineering is is is actually kind of
great but it's designed uh it's designed
and it's like a fully flushed up S uh
flushed uh fleshed out
structure that you just use as like a
cut scene generator pretty much M you
use it very rarely are we video game
reviewers now yeah um the one thing I
will say that I love I you know what I
hated though before you get into that
the pronouns that made me I
broke my computer I smashed my keyboard
pronouns I'm I said beist stop
current ding us that's what I saids
pronouns pronouns so the
one thing I do love that I think is so
cool is when you build or alter or get a
new ship and then you turn around and
you see it and it looks so epic and sick
seeing the ship that is very cool the
ship Builder is like too good for a for
a game where you the space travel sucks
the space travel sucks like combat's fun
especially if you space combat's pretty
fun yeah especially if you get like
certain skills like you definitely need
to get like targeting and stuff like
that cuz you can board ships if you do
that yeah boarding ship is awesome so
all that stuff is great except you know
that is like random occurrences doesn't
happen that frequently also they go like
you need to kill a certain amount of
ships to level up your piloting you I
don't even know where to go find ships
that's what yeah you you need to do
bounties you can do like Bounty right on
Bounty boards and stuff they have like
ships that you destroy um you can very
quickly beef that up there it is all
right thank you we're here to talk about
politics people the politics of
Starfield is uh a whole other thing
though to be honest everything is
politics and Starfield is part of
everything pronouns I'll tell you what
man those pronouns in space pron
I'm not here to play pronouns in space
do you understand stop current ding us
be
oh I hate it
I hate
it um tigerbelly friend of the show
actually uh love them both Obby Le and
Kila just had a huge guest who's
exclusive um RFK Jr and Carol
Cheryl that's right oh dude we got
have 1488 or whatever mic yeah that dude
straight up 1488 at us and now he's on
why isn't he why isn't he coming on the
we got to have we've been trying to
invite him on but these people are
cowards right dude it's cuz he he's
worried that uh your your uh
Superior ashkanazi Jewish jeans are are
he should be yeah you you we have 100 in
the building we just found out we have
what 100er Zach took a DNA test he's
100% he's that 100% that's crazy
he is literally 100% there's no way this
man is wearing a Rox hat just like I
just like I the the same one that I have
but not green I got to call you out
though man this is from the Concord the
Elegance in Pebble Beach where's ear
from oh hold up do you have Rox a watch
because um the hell he does damn bro
he's got his whole house he's got my
whole house on his I got your whole
house on my wrist crazy why
would you wear a Rolex hat and not have
the watch yeah I'm not a big watch guy I
don't really care I have
I'm not like uh I've never been that
into watches I think it's like silly I
do like Ro I think Rolexes are much
better than like some of the more
annoying ones like the Richard Millies I
hate those I love you h a very very good
analysis yeah I despise those
well Rolex is like originally a
workingclass uh pensioner gift Zach was
this a joke when you posted this yes you
sure 100% wait you changed the story cuz
you originally said it you didn't think
about it you didn't think about it
you did not think about this when you
posted this I'll let you guys decide
that
one this dud has a ro the Rolex had I
got from uh a friend of mine uh Miggy he
owns rru it was in the back of his uh
was in the back of his truck Rolex in
the back of his truck no the Hat oh
that's kind of sick dude and I guess his
friend made it for some golfing event
maybe the one that you went to like
literally anyway um RFK tells Bobby that
Jew's did Co and he's like yo that's
pretty interesting wait really no I
haven't watched it it just dropped like
an hour before we went live oh chery hin
is there too let's go no he says
yes did you know that Bobby that the
Jews invented
Goldy dude easy that's what sounds like
he did 18 it's game on 18 huh 1844 is a
new version of 1488 W 1488 um yeah but
that is what he sounds like like he he
does sound like that yeah um he goes you
I'm not surprised you hit a check point
the
you guys really have to work on
your RFK
impers damn okay it's very
jittery he's from Massachusetts so he's
got he's got an advantage there did you
guys know that Hitler really he did a
lot of good for the country of
Germany it's wild is wild CU like RFK Jr
uh one was uh friends with Sam Cedar
back in the day I know that how weird
and two was like a
major uh environmental activist right
that was his like big thing yeah who
like successfully sued on behalf of like
indigenous tribes and so he's kind
of a weird Paradox like he is genuine in
some ways and I like but like on other
ways he's completely so unhinged it's
like a cartoon character yeah no he's
like a massive uh he's a massive
antivaxer like there's no and and
apparently he's a he likes Adolf Hitler
I don't know if he likes Adolf Hitler I
think what the was that 1488
or whatever I don't maybe he someone in
his uh there's like no way that that
happened accidentally I don't think a I
don't think like a like a Massachusetts
lib from the Kennedy family is like
secretly Pro Hitler know but then like
he's close enough to somebody who is
who's he running a social media account
or something yeah no that I agree with
he probably hired some some like
and the post is still up by the way
yeah reminder all of this was incorrect
like I I know it was probably like a
Ronda santis style situation where they
were like oh like you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna sneak this in here you know what I
mean that sort of thing but I don't
think RFK Jr himself is like I mean he's
definitely he's definitely weird he
believes like weird anti-semitic
like ashkanazi Jews can avoid Co
alongside the Chinese the Chinese and
the Jews are in cahoots yeah that that
part is like definitely cuz when you're
a conspiracy theorist you have to become
anti-semitic it's the OG conspiracy
theory it's the only thing that glues it
all together yeah exactly there's got to
be like a group of people that are like
evil across the board and doing evil
and that's me and they're not you
know they're not creative or clever
enough I guess to come up with something
different like that's why I love talking
about the the Hibernian iracy like the
real conspiracy is that the Irish
dominate uh everything you know the
protocols of Scotland or Dublin the
protocols of Dublin you guys read that
one the Elders of Dublin you know come
up with something fun like why it's he
in a
box it's always the Jews man
it's like that part is like let's get
creative with this yeah come up with
something new talk about
Italians how Italians run the whole
you know what I mean all right let's
talk about politics but anyway RFK shut
out this is politics true actually it is
true Bobby Le did you know
that I'm worried about this you know
what you got that's what he sounds like
I know that's what he sounds like he
tweeted out antic bro he's they're
say you're on dude how can I be aess
when I'm able uh you're you're they're
going to say you're making fun of his
voice a cuz I have Tourette so I'm I
don't know if I I agree with Ethan cuz
this guy's like a in piece of yeah
there's certain things where the you
know the the gloves come off I got you I
got you but what do you if I have a
disability what does that make me you're
saying like you have the card yeah but a
I think it's more limited to like you
you can make Tourette's jokes you have
Tourette's a disability the card is kind
of a blank check brother really okay all
right yeah you don't have the you don't
have the vaccine Survivor
card you need to get you need to have a
vaccine accident first a vaccine injury
right no but so am I able or no I'm not
able I'm anti- a what what does that
mean you're if you're ableist it means
that you're someone who's able who's
making fun of the people who aren't able
right yeah and so if I'm not able you
can you can have a disability if I'm not
able then I'm a anti-
ableist not ableist you're confusing me
now I'm not falling okay you're the one
who's like let's talk about politics and
then you you're just take the
conversation away
like
all let's get off of RFK let's get off
of RFK right
now we haven't even watched we haven't
watched the episode we don't there's
nothing to talk about here let's move it
on moving right along all right where
are
we my my major my major problem with RFK
Jr is that like he's been uh
weightlifting for years and years jacked
and at the and he's so jacked
for no reason cuz like he barely puts up
like 45 Pounders on the incline dumbbell
bench press and I'm like come on dog
like you think it's you think it's
Stolen Valor he's on Droids I think he
doesn't care about certain vaccines I'll
just say it like that certain Jabs it
seems he doesn't have a problem with
this is why they love him on the Rogan
nightes this I mean I love this is why I
love him too look at this dude he's just
out here being jacked for I I want to go
lift with him how old is he is he seven
oh he has steroid nipple his nips look
like Joe's I have
cones look at this fit boy with a slick
smile Emoji I don't know his son his
son's hot and also kind of cool from
what I understand he's an interesting
guy his son yeah who's his son there's
Jun post Jun Jun sweared that's not his
son dude he's got massive hands too what
the look at his hands you guys whoa
yeah this is what I mean look look look
how look look at the weak that
this is some dad hand kind dad hand look
like he's so hot he you know I I'd say
he if he wasn't a Jew hater but
like you know I don't know I can't I
can't give him that you know
okay jeans at the
gym look at me I'm doing
[Music]
push Jesus I don't know what that sound
is and I don't want to know it's the
Gizzy bot oh this the gzy bot oh it's
the gzy bot okay got it so we've been
trying to get RFK on the show okay thank
you then Vivic says he only will come in
person isn't that weird no I love that
you do yeah I think that's cool I was
like let's do a zoom because I just I I
don't sometimes it's better to have a
little distance because I don't I'm not
sure I want to do want to do a whole
episode with him but I guess we could
but do you find it odd it'd be funny if
we kicked him out Midway through and
we're like we're got to do our own
episode get out of here get out of here
Vivic he did he did a in person Tik Tock
with uh Jake Paul yeah it's in the dock
here which is really funny he's like oh
yeah like our politicians are not in
touch with the youth and it's like this
is his son all jacked and
kennedies are like kind of hot what is
with them man
all he went to Ukraine too I think he
like literally fighting yeah I think he
literally went to
Ukraine what yeah what son Connor
Kennedy secret enlistment in Ukraine war
the he's he's hot and and whoa his
eye his right eye is f what
Jesus wait wait wait wait wait wait this
is that's not photoshopped this is why
they didn't assassinate him dog cuz he
was already up they were like we
can let him ride wait his fa his face is
melting the right side is falling okay
if you keep on him he's not
going to come out the show well why not
no he won't he won't come on the show if
we keep on him 100% yeah am I
seeing things you're
blow I don't I don't
know his face looks like okay all right
yep here I'll say this and then you
button me if it's not good his face
looks like his voice
sounds yeah that's not bad this F not
bad his face looks like
this I just you know maybe I'm gone too
far so many peoplebe I just I hate that
so many people just lost their
mind with the vaccine like yeah I I
hate it I hate it so much so frustrating
I need to enlist in
Ukraine I to look like that when I come
home all yeah so Viv speaking of Viv he
went to Ukraine to lose
weight good way yeah uh speaking of
Vivic let's see our
boy um future guest and friend of the
show uh did a collaboration with Jake
Paul huge way to um this man is really
connecting with the youth man and you
can tell that it's real genuine too like
he really gets it it's it's sick because
like it's a really cool way to lose
support cuz like who the is like a
DieHard Jake Paul fan you know somebody
had the great a great Insight one of
vivi's things is he wants to raise the
voting age to 25 right 28 is it even I
think it was 25 and so at the same time
he's connect he's like oh I'm trying to
reach the youth hey the youth you mean
the people you're trying to
disenfranchise okay you want to know
something crazy I think it's a five head
maneuver because what do the youth love
more than anything else not vo not
voting exactly he is saying like hey
vote for me one time and then you never
have to vote again so he's going to get
like 100% of the youth vote everyone's
going to go out to the polls and vote
Vivic because they hate voting look at
what Jake Paul wrote I love Jake Paul's
getting so active getting Vivic on Tik
Tok because I believe our politicians of
the future should connect with geny and
Millennials you mean the people he's
trying to disenfranchise right on social
on social where we all live and breathe
it's bizarre that in this day and age
our presidents have no connection with
us via social so here he is pointing his
finger left and right damn only 2,000
comments like what the I mean he's
got 86,000 likes okay that one it didn't
go viral but it went kind of viral well
Jake's I mean he's he has a big account
it didn't do well compared to his
other it's got less all these other ones
20 though yeah but the comments are
actually pretty good Vivic has terrible
policy plan is number
one actually there's a lot of dude
growing on me Jake brought Vivic on to
to have the one guy that has a worse
hairline than him look at this Vivic
just earned my vote I am 18
though 18year olds please come vote for
me it will be the last time you vote for
the next
decade yeah I promise he just lost my
vote I don't know how this was green lit
but somebody on his team is getting
canned this was a terrible
idea not sure I'd want to associate with
Jake Paul if I was running for
office not respond Bill we what that's
just a dude's name bro what a what an
own got he's got some he's got some what
that's that's a comeback you know dude
your name is Bill dude that's a fire
comeback that is this is the smartest
comeback you will get from an Ohio man
okay this is he used 100% of his brain
processing capacity for that one he put
his whole bag into it he looks like such
a stoe
man just nothing behind those
eyes I love it I love it isn't uh
doesn't ramas Swami also want to ban Tik
Tok okay I'm I'm a fan of that okay well
now I'm voting for him I think he's uh
I'm voting illegally for ramaswami and
and RFK Jr both of the guys show big
thing is he's extremely hawkish on China
right like that's like the foreign said
he wants to preempt a war against China
he wants to like fight against China but
he also kind of wants to like leave
Taiwan to China it's like very weird he
has like a very weird foreign policy
perspective on it right um the the
obviously like
by the entire intelligence Community our
state department obviously it's like
American policy but the whole like leave
Taiwan or or first leave Taiwan alone
and then give them all guns like make
Taiwan like America where every Taiwan
uh every person in Taiwan has a weapon
how do we feel about Taiwan Hanan China
or not Chan is it China or not China
that's the American policy whatever the
American policy is whatever the American
perspective your opinion you really
won't stay no I'm I'm I'm saying it it's
like one it's one uh one country two
systems you
know no it's not it's two different
countries really Taiwan and China is
that according to American foreign Pol
no what's your
opinion what's your opinion Taiwan
Independence my opinion on Taiwan is
that Taiwan is uh the the the
Chinese concept of Taiwan should remain
in the hands of the people in Taiwan who
it's independent who for the for the
record for the most part just believe to
not disrupt the ongoing uh the ongoing
relations uh with why you being so
carefully footed around this because I
know that there's going to be a sub
there's going to be a subed post with
like a million comments being
like Hassan wants everyone in Taiwan to
be killed because he loves China he's a
xiin ping that's what I heard that's
what that's what I just it's already
over you asked me that question it like
ingest and it's going to already no I
was genuinely curious what you think
about it um I thinker am using a I think
that overall it's a it's it's
contemporary history is complex at the
end of the day if the Taiwanese citizens
uh would ever put this up for a vote and
we're like we want to be an
independent nation it's up to them you
know what I mean done that uh no no what
Hassan said is true from everything I've
read the most most people in Taiwan
nowadays support just keep the status
quo like the kind of but
they the overwhelming majority the
overwhelming majority's consensus
opinion is that um the the they don't
want to disrupt relations with China and
they also like obviously if it was a
situation between like full Bown
Independence versus like becoming a a
Chinese State like becoming a part of
the Chinese state do do the people of
Taiwan like pay taxes in China like do
they vote in dets that they have like
travel status in China but the thing is
like as far as as far as uh
like as far as Chinese Taiwanese
relations goes like the original
Inception of the country is Taiwan is a
a a fascist dictatorship that America
recognized as the real china until
Richard Nixon uh normalize relations
with China and that's where they
implemented the uh they call it
strategic ambiguity which I call lying
hold on this says the that the current
administration of Taiwan maintains that
Taiwan is already an independent
country there is yes this does not have
to push for any sort of formal
Independence there are uh well that's
because they don't want to do like a
full-blown exactly they don't want to do
they don't want to disrupt the status
quo that's why they're saying that sure
they don't want to be invaded by China
they want autonomy while simultaneously
uh being under the the Chinese Banner
according they want independence but
they just want don't want to be like
attacked by China militarily well that's
part of it for sure so you you
understand how Taiwan was developed
nation state right like so ma purged and
and defeated uh the uh the the
counterrevolutionary forces uh they like
Taiwan has been a larger uh part of like
China historically and the original
Taiwanese uh claim was that the entire
mainland China belonged to to what is
now known as Taiwan and that was the
American foreign policy position as well
because you know China was Communist and
Taiwan was a fascist military
dictatorship so they were like oh yeah
we're going to we're just going to
completely ignore China until Nixon
normalized relations with China and then
Taiwan became a democratic country of
course with still a lot of uh
reactionary opinions uh overall but like
that's gone away in recent years I think
the younger Generations have a different
perspective on the matter um but overall
like historically speaking Taiwan and
China uh being the same country it has
been around for much longer than like as
Elon mus said Hawaii being an American
state much much
longer it's Taiwan is already
independent that's what I'm saying
people don't want a formal declaration
just because they don't want a
War but they they're not wanting to be
Hong Kong and get be re like consumed by
the
Chinese party they don't want to be Hong
Kong what's what what happened in Hong
Kong am I say in the right place no you
you're you are they were independent and
then they got eaten they were
not independent well they were they were
had some rights they were less
independent than Taiwan then they got
eat Hong Kong was bought by by you know
are you saying the people of Hong Kong
did not want to be there were certainly
people that did not want to be a part of
uh China absolutely um that is 100%
correct lot most of them a lot of people
took a lot of a lot of people enjoyed uh
having uh Western civil liberties while
simultaneously like being in a unique uh
in a unique position but now that China
already does uh regular trade with the
rest of the world cuz like at a time in
like the '90s Hong Kong was was seen as
like this uh prosperous middle ground
but uh since the 2000s like because of
an insane amount of development and
insane uh trade relations with the rest
of the planet uh there are tier one
cities that are even larger and and and
have more economic activity than Hong
Kong and and of itself and there was
always a timeline where Hong Kong was
going to be given back to China they
just accelerated it by uh like two
decades if I'm not mistaken cuz that was
a lease on Hong Kong so the people of
Hong Kong there were certainly a lot of
people in Hong Kong that did not
want but overall if you look at the
situation of Hong Kong right now it's
it's like they claimed that it was going
to be devastating and that has not
happened not that we know of because
they can't F they have no freedom of
speech
anymore okay they can't talk they lost
their is true you're right the what am I
what are we going to learn from them I
will not they have secret prisons I do
not agree with uh uh China's social or
or civil liberties uh policies I do not
agree with that at all that's why I
don't live in China live in America
however having said that you can just go
to Hong Kong and you can just go to
every part of China pretty much and see
for yourself this is no longer like the
uh the North Korea style hermit Kingdom
where like no information comes out like
we have a a a regardless we have a
ton of Chinese people that live in
America regardless it's not they had
rights they don't have rights now they
lost a lot of Rights H but whatever I
mean you're you're this is interesting
that you're very soft you're very uh
you're very um soft footed around the
issue of China you love China I I I
think China if you love China so much
why don't you marry it I once again I
don't live there I choose to live here
because of the issues that you just
brought up which is uh civil liberties
being uh taken away um no freedom of
speech wal Garden internet like there
are um there are certainly parallels to
the American state or the Western world
that you there are certainly comparisons
that you could make but overall that
kind of uh mechanism of control is is
one that I do not appreciate personally
which is why I choose to live here but
um as far as uh like cruelty oppression
like what you're talking about with
respect to Hong Kong um the the the
promises that Western media overall made
about like how China was going to crush
Hong Kong under its like ruthless
oppressive thumb has not
happened I don't think that was the
point I think the point was just that
there's whoever was you know vocal about
wanting to maintain certain rights in
Hong Kong was probably thrown in a
secret prison and never heard from
again I mean certainly there was
political dissidents are are definitely
political dissidents are definitely uh
like taken out back they're not they're
not killed or anything but even then
it's like completely unac and you know
they go for a beer and they don't come
back you know what I'm saying they
they're not good on that stuff 100% but
well anyway I was just curious I didn't
mean to open a can of worms but you say
you you think the people of Taiwan
whatever they want and it seems to me
that the people of Taiwan want
independence so I'm right with you there
brother Independence for Taiwan I think
one nation two
systems One Nation two systems
yeah which is the current like Israel
and uh Palestine oh my God you don't
want to go down that rabbit hole come on
now I'm just I'm just with
you I'm just trying to I'm just trying
to get you um that that part is like
literally I mean that is
a I mean that's a that's an advocacy in
the opposite direction in my opinion
where Independence for Taiwan you heard
it ear from is remember like the
overwhelming majority of people living
in Taiwan are still Han Chinese mhm
therefore despite the fact that it's a
separate country it's still like the
same people the language is the same
people would people will say Ukraine
belongs to Russia for that exact reason
I don't think Ukraine belongs to Russia
because
Ukrainian um Ukrainian nation state the
Ukrainian nation state project there are
similarities you're not wrong about that
but the Ukrainian nation state project
as a well-defined nation state has
always uh has has been around for much
uh much much longer than like Taiwan
being an independent nation state so the
so the the people's uh entitlement to
Freedom you can make a better argument
for Crimea being a separate uh country
than like I'm hearing is that it's just
a function of how long how old their
culture is how how entitled they are to
freedom it's not I don't I don't think
that it's like uh those two concepts are
not the two concepts at play here like
it's not like entitled to freedom versus
um uh entitled to freedom versus what
was the other thing that you said well
it just seems like you you're talking
about like their n they have some kind
of National Heritage or identity I well
the thing that I was mentioning there uh
the reason why I mentioned that is
because you were talking about uh making
a compar comparison between like Israel
Palestine being that being that like
yeah being that the same um the same
people I think makes that kind of
especially existing under the the
construct of having like one nation
state regardless with freedom of travel
in between it's literally like a mile
off the coast you know what I mean of
China um having all of that factors
into um like whether there's going to be
a assimilation or not and it there is no
even there's no need for assimilation
even they have like normal trade
relations with Taiwan you know what I
mean it's like that's why it's
considered to be a a um delicate
political conversation but one that uh
currently the the Curren system benefits
both and so if China takes military
action against Taiwan as some people
speculate may
happen yeah I mean that would be that
would not be good I I don't think that
that would be good I think that would be
really really terrifying um it would be
disruptive for the entire uh global
economy as well right but I'm just mean
like
from who whose Army are you
joining front line are you fighting I'm
moving to Taiwan I'm moving to
an Unis location I'm moving to an
undisclosed location I'm on the front
I'm going to be on a ship
Whoever has the best chips I'm fighting
for okay I'm a chip boy myself if it if
it wasn't for America China uh would
have some pretty solid chip technology
but America's like regularly trying to
stop that process like they went to the
Netherlands to be like you can't sell
China your chip technology which is
insane if you ask me it's
incredible the
um the takes in chat how many people are
like just the
uh the polarization of this topic it's
insane well of course there's
going to be polarization on the topic
because American the American Media has
been gearing people to be across the
board like vicious no matter what to any
foreign adversary China being the main
fore an adversary now so people are
going to be very passionate in their
defense and start saying we care about
the people in Taiwan you're not talking
about the people in Taiwan you don't so
it's the it's the media if it weren't
for the media's uh propaganda people
would not be uh siding with
Taiwan yeah I mean think about it this
way why the does no one care about
Yemen you know what I mean why because
Saudi Arabia is the one our our Ally
Saudi Arabia is the one doing the
genocide in Yemen you never see people
get this
passionate people get dis passionate
about Syria I think Taiwan has more
relevance to to the United States like
in terms of a economical you know and
social that was that was developed well
that's only natural that people would
care more about something that's that
affects them more I don't think Yemen
and I'm not saying it's right or wrong I
just don't think Yemen affects but it's
still people it's still people that are
being mercilessly slaughtered whereas no
one is being slaughtered in Taiwan in a
similar capacity and yet there are way
more passionate because not saying it's
right or wrong it is designed to to have
this kind of and you think that if
only reason people care about the
Ukraine is because of the
media absolutely 100% nobody would care
I yeah of course did anybody care about
Georgia yeah that's a great question
probably I don't know no no no one gave
a about Georgia that's
crazy hold
on well I mean what about in Europe they
seem to care about Ukraine a lot it's
the similar
principle media is still media
everywhere around the world I mean it
plays a very significant role in
people's lives Ukraine borders Europe
and I mean I'm not again I'm not saying
it's right or wrong but Georgia is not
really uh in such a
geographically uh strategically
important location as
Ukraine okay well I'm just explaining
why people might care more about Ukraine
than Georgia and I'm not saying it's
right or wrong I'm just saying still
people it's people being I'm just I'm
just saying cuz your your theory is that
the the support for Ukraine and Taiwan
is
essentially manufactured that it
wouldn't exist it it shouldn't exist I'm
not saying it shouldn't exist I'm simply
stating that I'm simply stating that the
it's manufactured people only care about
it because they've been tricked to
caring about it it's not tricked but
dude
like normal people don't think about
foreign policy are you saying that you
don't think that normal people's opinion
about like International matters are
shaped by what they see on the news and
what's prioritized I'll exle of course
it hold on hold on hold on because I'm
being double team now so I need to speak
of course it is but this implication
that you're like if you say nobody cares
about Taiwan or Ukraine because of the
media it implies that you know the
support for for those two countries or
care for those two countries is like you
know manufactured that it's really not
what you jumped to that nobody said no I
am I am saying that yeah he is saying
I'm saying that the support for the
overwhelming majority of Americans for
any country that any country that the
United States of America has a genuine
interest in is manufactured in either
direction it can be manufactured uh
carelessness and inconsideration like
being inconsiderate and and ruthlessly
violent at certain points which is the
example I was going to use with 9/11 and
what we did post 911 or it could be
manufactured in the other direction
where it's like this is the the just War
this is the just war that we have to
fight like they like we did in Vietnam
originally when there was uh when there
was need to generate popular support for
whatever kind of action America
consistently takes now I'm not denying
I'm not denying that propaganda exists
but I am saying that like the comparison
of Ukraine to Georgia is not it's not
apples to oranges that's all I'm saying
it's not
what I I what do you mean by this
Ukraine borders like uh Mainland Russia
or Europe okay Europe cares a lot about
it okay um I would say that it's uh
probably more I would say that in Europe
there's probably more of a uh a not
controversy necessarily but it's a more
divisive issue in uh I think Europe than
it is in America most likely it's also
like you know not the best precedent
when when like um like tyrants start
land grabbing in Europe generally
hasn't I I agree with you I think that I
think that in I understand why people
don't complely unjustifiable and it's
also even if you're like pro- Russia Pro
Vladimir Putin anti-nato right even if
you're all of those things it's a
laughably it is a laughably idiotic
thing to do because all you've done has
now galvanized NATO support in Europe
and Justified it um cuz that was the
entire reason for NATO's existence is to
stop uh the USSR stop communism from uh
from thriving and obviously you Russia
is is a very different country than the
USSR was and and is no longer
ideologically aligned with Communism at
all it is a um it is a state that
Western capitalist basically redesigned
uh and and propped up oligarchs
including people like Vladimir Putin so
uh despite all of that it's still
utilized as a uh as a as a protection
racket that you basically Justified its
existence of by doing such an
unimaginably cruel inhumane
unjustifiable act invading
Ukraine um so it is a it's a strategic
blunder even if you're like pro- Russia
I think that you're I just think people
are capable of caring about it without
well I mean I care like you know I I I
care about it people can sincerely can
care about it even though you know you
think it's unfair that people didn't
care as much about Georgia you know
that's my point as well it's not
necessarily just not caring about
Georgia my opinion on this is that we as
a as a nation here in America and all
around the world are are are not immune
to propaganda no as a matter of fact
every every piece of information that we
we analyze has a great impact on our
decision-making process and therefore
doing a full media blitz on any
particular issue is usually going to
yield these kinds of results and this
kind of support which without that kind
of media blitz would not
exist does that make sense again I'm not
denying that propaganda exists and that
we're all you know yeah
the example I was going to use was uh
our justification for the invasion of
Afghanistan and the invasion of Iraq uh
these were both unjustifiable Wars in my
opinion the war on terror was across the
board wholesale ruthless cruel led to
millions of people dying led to uh tens
of millions of people being
destabilized and and we're still living
in the in the rubble of that kind of uh
of that kind of cruel and unusual action
and it was championed by a majority of
the American population and until like
the past like couple of years where what
does that have to do with Ukraine being
invaded by Russia where do you think
that kind of attitude came from okay
where do you think that justification
came from there was a billion dollar
industry same thing man Ukraine was
invaded was invaded by Russia no it is
exactly the same thing literally a
tyrant grabbing land in Europe I agree
with what you're saying my point is uh
my propaganda exists yeah I know no my
point is that Americans think that they
are independent thinkers and yet they
are motivated into uh believing things
uh no matter what it is it can be a just
cause I agree that it can be a just
cause in the in the situation where
you're uh where you're supporting
Ukraine and Ukrainian Independence which
is an independent nation state you know
what I mean it's been an independent
nation state uh in the in the aftermath
of the the the dissolution of the USSR
it's been an independent nation state
you can't just like turn around and be
like all right it's mine now right I
agree with that
um and and that it can be seen as a uh
just just War an understandable War it's
it's not even a war that the Ukrainian
people wanted right um but having said
that the American support the full
throat of support uh is is absolutely a
doesn't seem like there's full thred
support there's a lot of people that
don't support it there's a very diverse
opinion of uh if you looked at if you
looked at polls in the original Invasion
the amount of support like there's a lot
of conservative people who are like
Putin simps and then there's also a
bunch of like lefties like and I mean
that rogatory those aren't Realties who
aren't like uh who who are like the guy
we were speaking to the Communist
Professor R wol yeah who's like kind of
um he he people like him are also very
anti Ukraine in general I don't know I
don't know his entire perspective
I don't think you can be Pro if you are
offering even critical support to Russia
or not Russia but like Vladimir Putin in
general I don't think I don't think
you're doing the right thing I I don't
know what's his position cuz he didn't
really flush up I think you're lost in
the sauce I think you're lost in the
sauce in the sense that um me or him no
no like anyone that is like oh no
Vladimir Putin did the right thing he
has like he has to have this I don't
think people are saying that I think
what I hear is like Ukraine uh um
zalinski is also you know a starter
and uh it's their problem that we
shouldn't get involved
in I don't know I think there's a lot
there are there are people who like
claim to be socialist or or even
Communists that are like you know
defending Vladimir Putin but they're
they're marginal what Dan you seem to
think that UK the Ukraine
uh the Ukraine Wars and something
American should get involved in when did
I ever say that what are you talking
just based on your what you were saying
about Georgia no we were having a
discussion about how media shapes
narratives in the United States and I
was saying that in again I'm not talking
about in Europe I'm not talking about in
the rest of the world in the United
States the Russian invasion of Georgia
was a non-story nobody gave a here
but it's different it is different there
is difference it it was a Sovereign
Nation that Russia invaded what you
because it doesn't it's not it doesn't
have the same proximity or the same
importance within uh uh as Ukraine I
think right but I we're talking past
each other like that that I'm not
Ukraine is more important to the United
States strategically that's why it gets
attention we're saying the same thing
yeah right but I'm okay I we're I know
people are influenced by the media right
but you were saying you think that
people you know allowed to care about
things genuinely nobody saying saying
you're not allowed to I mean not allow
to but you're Hassan was saying what was
I saying that it's a manufactured uh
support it absolutely is yeah that is
something that the US media does they
manufactur support for us for you were
saying I jumped to conclusion I'm not
saying that it I'm not saying that all
US foreign policy is bad but I think it
is unquestionably true that the US media
crafts people's of course CFT The
Narrative so so what is the disagreement
then like what if I maybe I'm not using
uh there the implication that support
for Ukraine or Taiwan is not authentic
right that you're purely for us
propaganda that's not neily true and
then you Dan
said examples I use examples I use are
always like America has what 800
military bases all around the planet we
have our hands in everyone's Pockets
right and uh there are active there's
active conflict happening everywhere
around the Planet all the time and the
United States is involved in it if you
are not thinking about it if you're not
thinking about something uh happening
specifically that is because for the
most part the media has not covered it
the mo for the most part the media is
all right I'm over it let's move on and
I think that that that is deliberate
that is by Design like it's like just
not even fun to watch probably at this
point or talk about
okay you want to talk about Len Lauren
bobbert being a
psycho we can do that
sure here she
is it looks like a Nazi era
vintage
video where it does doesn't it looks
like they're oh like the
rallies oh the the M the what is it
night at Madison Square Garden it's
familyless footage of bobbert being
kicked out of a out of Beetlejuice in
Denver she's literally a just a hooligan
drunken Patron freak who's also a
congress person powerful one too
apparently she was ripping Vapes this is
here she I this is so crazy and hooting
and
hollering taking taking pictures ripping
her Vape singing along with the musical
which I think is the funniest part to
me and I think that this is uh 19
84 this is this is 1987 George Orwin
okay that's what's going on this is
animal Factory this is this Animal
Crossing brother let me tell you
why so the Usher America not China okay
I thought this was America and not the
chaom
leadership so the Usher is saying Hey
listen uh you got to go you have to
leave you're ruining the show for
everyone
uh yeah you congresswoman famous
congresswoman powerful you have to
leave you need to leave right now you
drunken
freak and of course she bust that do you
know who I
am this is awesome is there video of it
or just a Rec no there's more there's
more there's like other cameras that
they posted so many camera angles
different angles it's pretty fire I've
only seen where they put all the camera
angles together on like line and
like police recru events that's that's
what they did here it's wild um she's on
a date good for her Queen uh she uh you
know is divorced from her sex offender
uh husband yo they prepared the
big guns out here it's Larry and Jeff
out here that Allstar Usher is about to
kick her ass out I'm telling you it's
okay if you want to rip fat
Vapes and sing along to your favorite
theater to your favorite musical theater
yeah you should be able to do so it's
it's your god-given right this is
America constitutionally protected she
wasn't yelling fire in a crowded theater
she was simply enjoying the show
okay it's all I'm
saying is awesome Olivia is our uh
resident musical theater expert um have
you ever sang at a u musical when you
were in attendance
just out loud has Beetlejuice encouraged
collaboration absolutely not no that
would be considered a poor
ethical very poor etiquette poor poor
stage etiquette yeah got it so that's
kind of embarrassing to be kicked out of
the show halfway through huh and
escorted out too isn't it she's been
escorted out by the big boy ushers she
just thought she was going to a concert
she is ready for the club look at her
outfit dude her date is trying
to let me get a look at her date is this
she is in a little Club dress she's
definitely got her her pumps she's
having fun she got all she got the eagle
now at the
Broadway hold on let me see her date I
get to peep this guy he's it's the guy
in the blue uh this guy here with the
bag yeah yeah bro you better defend your
girl more than that what's this little
hand
wve
what's in the bag
anyway The Vape right yeah yo they got
the whole gang up on this look at all
the ushers mom I want a
vape time to
go enjoy Congress enjoy uh in impacting
the uh the process of American
democracy then it continues outside
where I think there was a oh look at
this this
this is the wild they the twirl yeah do
you see the twirl they had a great time
shame dude this is a walk of shame good
for
Lobo she's like I will not sh I'm going
to act like I'm not bothered that I just
got ejected publicly from Beetlejuice
good for good for her who amongst us
hasn't gotten face drunk
and wanted to rip fat Vapes in the
middle of uh in the middle of musical
theater happening she is trash she's
like a certified mess right now it's
awesome
yeah okay this is this is where it
really starts to trip me out this video
it keeps going how many security c i I
have more respect for her now yeah no
went my way up in my ratings of con
people I think she's uh she's living the
Tom of her life she live in Lita Loca
okay she's awesome man we pay her a fat
salary and that's good yeah yeah for
sure how much does she make you like
74,000
$174,000 a raise recently maybe I don't
know what the current see
house uh salary bber she's on the street
bro she's on a public Street and we
still got her ass on camera that's what
I'm wondering nine news like how did
they get access we got our eyes on you
girl don't even try it's still
going she's like a block away also
nothing's happening it's just like
they're just flexing on yeah no it's a
it's it's 174,000
still4 Grand yeah since since
2009 damn since 2009 Brandon's inflation
what's happening they they got to raise
that salary up jacked that up she
deserves it she deserves every penny
yeah and how long and how many times
when does she work how when is she quote
in the
office uh I don't know does she even
have to go to she doesn't even really
have to go do she I yeah you don't you
don't you don't you don't have to go
it's a much it's a much Freer process
than like the average salaried employee
when you're a salaried employee of the
state you don't have to go hm
according to Denver Police uh they said
the two patrons were escorted out and
reached the building's vestibule they
resisted leaving and said stuff like do
you know who I am and she said I am on
the board of yada yada and I will be
contacting the mayor shut up shut up
contacting the mayor I want to use it's
such a drunk person thing to say it's
like what what are you going to tell the
mayor like I should be able to Vape in
the theater and be loud and drunk like
Denver this is not communist China I
will have you know that I will be
driving home drunk right now and any of
y'all try to pull me over I will be
telling the
mayor oh God that would have been so
fire if she got pulled over oh my God
she probably would she drove drunk she
100% here's the thing she almost lost
she almost lost her uh last election if
you guys remember yeah uh like she won
by a very tiny margin if she drove drunk
and got arrested by cops she would
literally win in a landslide even after
the redistricting that happened like she
would literally win other districts they
would they would form a new Rifle
Colorado District that
was Mega District why because they would
there would be a theory that uh it was a
democratic uh hit job to arrest no
Americans Love Drunk Driving they love
drunk driving yeah P time it's a
national
Pastime I heard this clip is great
there's another
related why are you playing this phony
uh this phony folk hero who went
to burning man he didn't no we got he he
got dup he didn't go to burning man but
he's like charging there's new drama on
him he's charging 120 Grand per
show what yeah that can't be true Tim P
ripped him a little bit really because
he was Mr like I don't care about the
money I just care about the people he
HEK he canel show in this like smaller
venue because apparently the venue was
charging $200 to $90 a ticket and that's
expensive yeah he was like this is
like my tickets need to be $25
to
$45
except what he's charging the venues
apparently is1 120 Grand and then
complaining that they're and Charing too
and the ven was like bro what are you
doing like we have to we have to
make these ticket prices please let that
be true cuz the burning man thing wasn't
true there's there's drama yeah no
reading about it right now
125 what a phony so it's damn sh
that's a lot of fudge rounds dude the
venue which promised to refund ticket
holders within the next few business
days went on to explain the details
surrounding alliv Anthony's contract for
the concert the north man nor uh the
north man of Richmond contracted to play
The Cotton Eyed Joe for $120,000 for
Cotton Eyed
Joe
yeah here we come you guys see I make
fun of the South but to much but this
man's about to play at a venue called
cotton ey Joe where did you come from
where'd you
go so so he uh yeah so he charged 120
grand for 40 minute
show0 but but uh let me tell you
something let me tell you something okay
so he came out and was like I've only
made
$35,000 uh from a show like not a lot of
gu no no that makes sense 35 Grand no he
just did a whole thing about I don't
care about the money he do free shows as
well too but like obviously it makes
sense that uh you would uh you would
charge for he should be doing free shows
the way he talk about those fudge he
does he does do free shows well I'm I'm
being super fair and balanced to Oliver
Anthony I know there's a lot of Oliver
Anthony heads out there that get very
mad at me whenever I like call them like
really we're this is not a friend we
we're not a pro Oliver Anthony show here
I just like I I don't really care
personally I think he's like a I mean
there was a video where he like fudge
rounds
but so it doesn't affect
you it it doesn't that's why I'm yeah
that's why I'm not passionate about this
see cuz I'm not using uh I'm not using
my my uh EBT on fudge
rounds so can you do me a favor how much
fudge rounds does 10 did you say
120,000 yeah 120,000 fud rounds can you
buy with
120,000 look I think on I think what's
going on here is that the drama is like
a little bit
manufactured um and that
overall
overall uh the the uh the
situation happened because uh he
probably has like bad management who's
like charging 120 Grand but then maybe
he's not seeing all of it I don't know
yeah it's probably those right-wing
grifters that jumped all over him to
like produce his next album and all that
right could see that I didn't pull this
up in time but when we were talking
about Starfield no no they showed it oh
we showed it oh you did good we see it
um so a box of eight fudge rounds is
about eight uh 10 bucks so it's about
like a dollar 12110 per fudge round
right okay you're right yeah so how much
is so you're looking at 130,000 we're
saying mhm mean we're looking at like
12,000 120 100 we're looking at like
110,000 fudge rounds m it's a lot of
fudge rounds brother my friend fudge I
don't work for money I work for fudge
rounds you can you can said the fudge
rounds to my
people he he's really he really went off
on the fudge rounds he hates fat know
it's just Jesus he his his counter to
this was so funny cuz like it's really
interesting because like he doesn't he
never had to like do a correction on
this he could have just like leaned
further into like the right-wing
which he kind of didn't so I do have
like some kind of respect for him on
that front where he was just like no
actually what I meant was like the food
that people are having is like really
bad for them which was his
counter was but he didn't lean
into it which I think is commendable his
counter was uh but yes
uh coming out and and saying like no
actually it's not like that uh I I
respect it's commendable um interesting
guy overall you know big fan uh love
love hearing his voice his beautiful
voice uh you know looking forward to his
careering and 300 lb I could make a lot
of fuel from your old fat
rounds one use your oil to burn my
candle I don't know you want to read so
this guy John Kennedy is he a Kennedy or
like a fake Kennedy well he is a Kennedy
but not he's a Kennedy but not from the
family not a Ken you know about John
Kennedy said my favorite my favorite
Louisiana's finest mhm he's a fake but
phony fake Kennedy how dare is
he even antia how dare yes he definitely
okay good so what do you mean he's he's
a republican congressman from Louisiana
Louisiana it's a safe so anyway there's
a clip of dear I will quote from it joh
Senator John Kennedy who is uh
protesting the usage of lewd books being
shared with our dear kids well it
technically it's not even like little
children and and this is not a part of
the curriculum this is George M
Johnson's book about growing up it's a
memoir about growing up uh black and
queer uh and uh and John Kennedy thought
it was
so
unimaginably uh
unacceptable to to have this kind of
pornographic material that he chose to
read an excerpt in the Senate hearing
let's see there's certain excerpts from
the LGBT book that conservative parents
have been seeking to remove from schools
so they aren't accessible by kids so
here let's read let's hear I mean maybe
he's got a
point let's let's hear him out all boys
aren't
blue and I will quote
from I put some lube on and got him on
his
knees mhm and I began
she's laughing bro who are you I like
her she awesome I like her whoever you
are immediately she's like oh him from
behind I pulled out of him and kissed
him while he masturbated go on he asked
me to turn over while he slipped a
condom on himself mhm keep going this
was my ass and I was struggling to
imagine someone inside me right he got
on top and slowly inserted himself into
me it was the worst pain I think I have
ever felt in my life that was eventually
I felt a mix of pleasure with the pain
oh God close quote all boys aren't
blue oh my goodness all boys AR that was
quite graphic
sir and also my favorite thing is is
just like reading and showing things
that you find
uh are are like unimaginably like gross
and unacceptable in a congressional
hearing you're going to look gender
queer uh okay let me read an excerpt
from that
quote this is a different book I got a
new strap strap on harness today okay I
can't wait to put it on you okay it will
fit my favorite dildo perfectly you're
going to look so hot
I can't wait to have your in my
mouth nice going you're going to pull
that right d he put that with a little
too much emphasis get into this to have
your in my mouth sir he's he's like
he's like licking his lips his mouth is
salivating while reading this like I
canot oh wait I missed a good line here
my mouth I'm going to give you the
of your life then I want you
inside of me
oh yeah wow that is Graphics so what's
the what's the what's the goal here
right like is the question you must be
asking yourself and the goal is to like
ban these books in libraries and
yeah and it's so stupid okay
it's so entirely stupid uh the allowance
uh of books like this in libraries is
perfectly valid perfectly reasonable
especially if you're like a queer
teenager this could be formative
nobody's reading books anyway
but like this is not this is not
pornographic okay if you're getting
horned up by this it's a lot easier to
find that's you like that's on you you
know how much harder it is to check this
book out than just pull up porn I know
which well you know they want to ban
that too but like the Free Speech
Defenders uh which uh Republicans claim
to be right uh that's that's what they
did throughout the the uh the second
term of the Obama presidency everyone
was like oh sjw's like they hate Free
Speech they ha Free Speech even back
then while they were doing that
conservatives were propagandizing that
they were the real free speech Defenders
while simultaneously trying to
ban books like this too and and they've
been doing it they have never stopped
doing it and they are doing it again and
it is deeply frustrating
because like they portray this as like a
a six-year-old will like go pick up this
copy and like read it and then I don't
know what will happen to the
six-year-old I guess like they be gay
they they'll be gay I guess but like um
it's really really all boys are blue
yeah it's really
frustrating um it's not it's not a part
of the curriculum it's just a book in a
Library okay and libraries yeah
and they should be allowed but you know
I don't know the context even of the
whole book I'm sure that you can't just
take one line out of a book you know
what I mean like no it is a memoir yeah
it is a memoir from George M Johnson and
their uh experiences growing up black
and queer that's it and and it was
written with the expressed purpose of
like helping other black queer
questioning teenagers and adults uh you
know form and shape their identity a
little bit better or at least have like
the terms to communicate their uh their
their gender expression I'm going to put
I'm going to give you the of
your life sir it's just so
annoying clip thator the words you spoke
are disturbing especially coming out of
your mouth is very disturbing but I I
the words you spoke are disturbing
especially coming out of your mouth is
very disturbing thank you King who is
this he's actually the Secretary of
State of is he Pro or against he is Pro
groming or anti-g groming yeah I'm not
sure which uh I'm coming he is against
Banning the books that's
what I am too I think it's
ridiculous and and the the irony the
irony here is that like the first book
burning
that happened in na Germany on and got
him on his knees I I didn't the first
book burning that happened in Nazi
Germany was literally transmed research
they went into this uh right they went
into a a medical facility that was like
doing Cutting Edge uh research on on you
know trans people somebody said hold on
Ethan would you let your kids read those
books I mean I don't I don't know
anything about the book I don't my kids
would not read that book it's about kids
it's not for kids like it's not no I
would not let my four-year-old read that
book why would I book he can't read by
the way he can't read my son can't read
I'd have to read it to him that be weird
like but that that's that's such a
stupid counter you know what I
mean that's such an idiotic
counter because like the reality is even
if I don't want uh my potential child in
the future uh I don't know this
is not even a good example I was going
to say a Rand but like I also don't give
a if uh they would read that cuz
would expect them to be smarter than
than uh believing in that dumb
libertarian nonsense the truth is like
we're talking about a whole Library full
of books if you want to go through every
of the tens of thousands books in there
for sexual passages and ban them all go
ahead you ban the Bible yeah ban the B
the Bible then but that that
book is there to help some people
there's a group of people that that book
will help so and the other people are
not looking for that book right right so
so you wanting to ban that book because
you're afraid you're I I can't imagine
that anyone under the age of 10 would
stumble upon that book and just start
reading it no there's no for no reason
there's no world of wi and plus there's
like a structure like the librarian will
be like no you you shouldn't read that
book read this book instead you know
what I mean point maybe not but the
point is it's there to help some people
okay the people who is very Niche I mean
listen if your kids reading that book
they probably have a curiosity and
they're probably old enough to
understand what those concepts are this
was actually later in the uh in the same
session holy Fu they're also trying
they're also trying to ban um what is it
is this is this like Ninja Turtle yeah
is it a pregnant looking for someone
that's really upied
Leonardo I'd like to titty her dude
oh god oh Jesus first of all that'd be
like it' be a hard shell right right
behind you by the way he's like laying
right by the way I saw n Turtles movie
with with Theodore it was really good oh
really awesome I heard good
things about it it's good like the man
look at the rack on that Turtle anyway
here's
[Applause]
more uh put some lube this is the one
that we watched oh we watched this one
already that was the part two yeah oh so
wait got him on his knees yeah yeah yeah
hold
on so wait there's more there's there's
more I can't I got a new strap strap
wait we watched all these just he
reposted just that part cuz it's so
funny I got myself a strap on dildo and
I like the size and feel of it right put
it on here I wanted to show you guys
this um looked at myself when the me
were a good 10 minutes here we go boy I
really like the side of that look down
at my old small pecker there and wish
myself had a big old one like this here
strap one well I like the way wear the
strap on out sometimes make me feel like
a
man I I go outside with a big old strap
on boy all right I ride the subway see
the package there and I'm not talking
about Amazon know what I'm saying
mhm I will go out to the club meet some
folks that notice my package I tell them
come home find
out that's right I never take it off
folks I am taking off having wased
without it coming on one year now a
little bit of a smell coming off it but
the size is all worth
it sometimes it's so long and nice I can
twist it around penetrate my own ass all
right that's what he said I think I I
think going back to the serious thing is
is uh these guys are out of
control uh it's not about banning a
specific book it's it's only one aspect
of a of a full throated war that the
Republicans uh the conservatives are
waging against all matter of uh gender
expression or all matter of the
expression of sexuality that does not
correspond to male female
heteronormative standards cisgender
heter normative standards there's got to
be like straight sex sces tons of them
that Library the the example I used and
and some of them want that band too they
want like you know F50 Shad of gray you
can't have in a library and it's like
shades of gay yeah it's it's laughable
to be like you should ban that like
you're a psycho okay if that's
your goal um did you show this
yet awesome Beetle Bert Beetle b bber um
I hate I hate this Banning books
nonsense
um they do it with television as well
they did it with like PBS in in Alabama
if you remember the episode of Arthur
where there was like gay marriage
happening was that the one that Crowder
was in uh no I don't think Crowder was
in that one but overall all this stuff
is nonsensical is but uh it is
a it is only one flank of a much larger
War take it off bro that's offensive
much lure war against uh existence
in general they're doing this on the
legislative Side by making it uh uh
basically illegal to be transed in
public making it illegal to transition
all this stuff um it's really up
there's not enough support for it either
they're just kind of doing it for the
fun of it they're doing it because they
they want this level of control they're
doing it to appease some of the more
radical factions within the base of the
Republican Party the the all of those uh
lobbyist groups with family uh in their
names the the the Christian
fundamentalists and
um I I
just I get I get really frustrated
when I when I see stuff like this um
especially because that's not how that's
not how gender works you don't like see
gay marriage and become gay you know
what I mean that's not that's not how
that works they know deep down
inside that that's not how that works
they want to stop it because they don't
want that expression to they don't want
someone to be comfortable with their own
identity because they themselves are not
comfortable with their own identity um
that's it they just want to make it as
hard as possible to come
out and and they want to cast it aside
and it's very
frustrating
yeah
um yeah I mean like like we said how
much there's like straight incest like
nice good incests like like that would
make you know team SK flush in the Bible
yeah like there are so many books that
you read from eth grade onward even in
the American even in the American
curriculum that has like brutal
depictions of sexual assault American
history or history in general has brutal
depictions of genocide torture rape all
that stuff like how are we sanitizing uh
this why are we sanitizing is the first
question how are we
sanitizing yeah exactly it's
the Bible has way more uh
brutal depictions of sex with your
father with your sister isn't there one
like that where the twin like two girls
their dad there's one in the Bible
there's in the Old Testament there's a
passage uh in the Old Testament there's
a passage of uh uh what Hunter Biden did
basically which is cracken having sex
with your uh with your recently deceased
uh uh brother's wife yeah right well
there's that's a victimless crime yeah
I'm just saying that like but that's sex
like they're the Bible has sex and and
depictions of your sister-in-law
but that's a good thing right cuz you're
you're supposed to take them when your
bro passes you take over yeah yeah
that's dope yeah that's that's fine
that's allowed that's good Bible
like oh the the example I was going to
use the last example I was going to use
before we move on to Kevin McCarthy's
you know incredible Biden impeachment
inquiry which will certainly uh yield
positive results
um in Florida when the don't say gay
was popping off uh like the one of
the examples that was used commonly was
like oh if you're a queer teacher you're
not allowed to have like if you're let's
say male teacher you're gay you're not
allowed to have a photo with your uh
with your husband at school right and
like conservatives do this thing where
they go oh if you're gay in public
you're you're you're promoting gay sex
like if you're holding hands in public
you're promoting gay sex cuz I can't
stop thinking about gay sex right like
that's the that's the mentality and you
would never say that about like a
pregnant teacher you know what I mean
like oh my teacher my my daughter's
teacher in Kinder Garden's pregnant you
know what that means that means she
which means she's walking around
showing everybody how much she
had heterosexual sex it's kind of a
self-report because their very existence
in their mind is sexual that's what I
mean it's like it's like hypersexualized
I see a gay man and I just think about
wanting to suck a man's penis I think
about that's what they do and it gets me
thinking about it makes me uncomfortable
but but that that normative standard is
how it is the reason why uh a lot of
people are able to get away or or a lot
of people are able to get away with like
bigoted perspectives uh while shielding
it under uh our our puritanical values
like oh I just don't want any mention of
sex and it's like no you don't you are
the one who's you know connecting the
dots there and and saying that like
queer existence is inherently sexual
when it's not you don't think that way
about uh heteronormative cisgender uh
relationships
um thank
you thank you sorry no you're right I
support I'm with you 100% brother you
know what I'm saying dicks out
brother uh here is we're got to hit on
these main topics real fast so Kevin M
McCarthy is getting desperate the hunter
biter thing isn't providing any juice
for impeachment that's apparently
turning into the thing now we just got
to impeach whoever whoever
said they were going to do that they
were like oh yeah if you do this to
Trump we'll do this to you and it sucks
for them because like Biden is uh really
hard to do this with because like he's
kind of boring he's a little too boring
um but so there so this is an
interesting strategy usually right you
need the House vote to impeach a
president uhuh but but Kevin has said
what if we don't and that I think is a
compelling argument legally speaking so
here he is announcing that
that despite these serious allegations
it appears that the president's family
has been offered special treatment by
Biden's never seen that before
president's family being offered special
treatment yeah that's that's never
happened yeah especially not in Trump
thank God they're addressing nepotism
finally in in um in in you know familiar
relations god
dude treatment that not otherwise would
have re
right if they were not related to the
President right huge problem these are
allegations of abuse of power
obstruction and
Corruption and they want further
investigation by the House of
Representatives but they did that that's
why today yeah exactly I am directing
our house committee to open a formal
impeachment inquiry into President Joe B
on support of the house this logical
Next Step will give our committees the
full power
supports and answers for the American
public I just see two brave men they're
such the answers ah hey Dy nice to see
you one one is dead that piece of
how many Rockies you killed Papa
chairman James comr at the committee on
oversight in coordination with chairman
Jim Jord okay so can we pause it for a
second couple things here okay number
one the the uh investigation committee
uh which was done behind closed doors
for a very specific purpose and the
purpose was to like muddy the waters and
lie about all the information that they
couldn't find connecting Hunter Biden to
Joe Biden um that's number one number
two republicans in Congress have said
that there isn't enough information
connecting Hunter Biden to Joe Biden uh
as far as like Hunter Biden's uh level
of access and influence in the
decision-making process of the American
government as as it pertains to foreign
policy specifically in Ukraine so that's
number two and
number three Kevin McCarthy himself
personally gave a quote to Breitbart
last week where he said of course we're
going to hold this up for a vote okay
hold us up for a vote to to launch this
inquiry and then obviously didn't have
the votes to do that so now he's
trying to do it without actually uh
anyway putting it up for a vote so every
aspect of this is so haphazardly put
together Mitch McConnell himself has
openly stated uh as of like two days ago
that's interesting cuz he can't really
openly State anything yeah he's just he
gathered he gathered the last remaining
uh health bar and juice that he had to
say yeah we'll wait for the house to do
its thing the Senate is a whole
different kind of issue you know he went
like this the House
[Music]
Republicans
yep I don't know why I keep making this
joke because uh the doctors cleared him
so yeah he's healthy he's uh he's a
beacon of health and prosperity he
bumped his head apparently yeah he's
just he's fine he had a little oopsy he
pooped his pants that would have been
way funnier if the medical professionals
was like yeah he had a he had a sharting
incident it' be moreable first time
that's what I thought happened my pants
I straight up just thought he his
pants and he was like froze up not
knowing what to do but my client bumped
his head and he just locks the beer off
sometimes mid sentence
like sometimes happen to the good old
boys had a little too much sweet tea in
the morning you know what I'm
saying anyway so that's pretty fun um
yeah there didn't seem like a lot of
support or juice at all for this so so
here's what's going on uh did Hunter
Biden utilize the Biden name to get jobs
that he had no business having I of
power AB lutely one of those one
of those was in Ukraine in an energy
company called burisma okay where he got
a job without any
yeah without any prior experience
whatsoever part of the reason why he got
this Consulting gig was because he lied
about having access to his dad ah um
part in that in that process he also in
an effort to show everybody how much
access he had to his dad he had like
phone conversations with his dad in
front of those guys but according to the
actual testimony from uh Devon Archer
the other person that was investigated
by the house committee the rep his
business partner right his business
partner yes no in none of those
conversations did they ever actually
discuss work and it was more so like him
putting his dad on speaker phone telling
everyone to be quiet to show that he had
like to show that he could have a phone
conversation with his dad so that Hunter
Biden is a piece of work I it's pretty
funny it's pretty funny this is like Bo
Biden was also like dying of cancer so
his dad is probably more likely to
pick up the phone call dude that
Hunter really is something yeah so yeah
the goat so all of that stuff is is true
like nepotism all that stuff is 100%
real the point is if you want to impeach
uh you know a a a president for having a
fail son you have to somehow tie the
fail son back to the president and there
is no paper trail that they've been able
to find there's no conclusive evidence
that they've been able to find and now
they're just kind of saying like the B
they've decided the way to massage the
narrative in the absence of evidence
hard evidence that could directly tie
you to the the wrongdoing that you're
alleging specifically that like
Brandon uh pressured the Ukrainian
government to fire Victor shoken the
Ukrainian uh prosecutor at the time
right he did this because he wanted to
help his son Hunter and justify Hunter's
salary
that is the argument in order to make
this argument stick you have to have uh
a couple different uh pieces of
information you have to have some kind
of paper trail or you have to at the
very least have some uh uh like
conclusive evidence that Hunter Biden
and Joe Biden had conversations
specifically about his uh burisma job
and and like and last but not least and
this is probably the most important
aspect of this because this is something
I covered all the way back in 2019 when
the original Trump conversation was
happening with Ukraine if you remember
the this the impeachment trial happened
because Trump had a phone conversation
with Ukrainian officials where he said
give me dirt on Joe Biden and Hunter
Biden as it pertains to barisma and if
you don't show me dirt I'm going to stop
uh giving you Military Support which was
already congressionally approved so we
didn't even have the presidential power
to be able to stop that from happening
right so that's why he got impeached uh
uh if you guys remember first time and
at the time um it was already known it
was already welln and well established
that Victor shoken was a corrupt
prosecutor that literally ukrainians
wanted to to uh remove from position
Civil Society organizations that are
involved in Ukraine wanted to remove
from that position uh the International
Community wanted to remove him from this
position the IMF and the World Bank
wanted to remove him from this position
of and they were even saying that they
were going to stop giving loans to
Ukraine unless they remove this
prosecutor from a position of power um
so they they they claimed that like it
was Hunter Biden that got this
prosecutor removed but that's
idiotic because the CIA wanted him
removed right the Civil Society
organizations that had interest in
Ukraine wanted him removed Ukraine was
already uh a a important uh Ukraine was
already like you've mentioned an
important country for American interest
in the nation there was it was both
simultaneously in the western sphere of
influence on the one hand but also in
the Russian sphere of influence on the
other and Victor shoken was a longtime
uh Ukrainian official that was you know
on this delicate tight RPP and he was
leaning too much in the Russian
direction for the Western interest in
the country to be comfortable with right
and that was the major reason why they
wanted him of this position and also
because he was corrupt but everyone's
corrupt uh like let's be real
right
so at the end of the day the one aspect
of this story that I find really
hilarious is that Victor shoken the
corrupt prosecutor that Biden pressured
Ukraine to
remove was also holding up
investigations on barisma yeah so he was
literally working in favor of bisma yeah
interesting and being fired was bad for
that yes him being fired was bad for
bisma because he had held up an
investigation that the the UK officials
were conducting where they stopped the
the UK officials from actually seizing
burisma Executives assets to the tune of
millions of dollars so why the
would Hunter Biden want this guy
fired if anything if he didn't get fired
after all of those Civil Society
organizations that had interests in
Ukraine wanted him to be oued from his
position if he didn't get fired then it
would be improper then it made have
might have you might have had a leg to
stand on with respect of like what Biden
was doing because Joe Biden acted on the
opposite interest of his son in that
situation another interesting thing that
I read was that um when Biden
Administration found out that Hunter got
that job they launched their own
internal investigation to figure out
like what the was going on that's
pretty well documented you mean the the
Obama Administration cuz Biden was yeah
he was a so there was an Obama
administration investigation cuz they
were worried about it at the time like
what the is this like yall got to
get your son in check cuz it makes us
look this looks horrible and it's all
well documented you you want to know
another really funny thing K file on CNN
found this Andrew um there was a
bipartisan letter of support from
Republicans and Democrats alike at the
time pushing to remove Victor shoken
from his prosecutorial power
so Republicans wanted this they
Hunter Biden delivered on our promise
and and here's the thing the reason why
there was so much bipartisan support for
Ukraine at a time when no one was
talking about Ukraine even though uh
Russia and Russian involvement in
Ukraine was already happening in the
Eastern territories of dones and and uh
LPR and DPR right there was back and
forth shelling thousands of people were
already dying even though people in
America did not know about it or care
about it at the time but there was
bipartisan support why because it was in
the American strategic interest that's
why there was bipartisan support that's
why when we were funding the azov uh uh
part of the Ukrainian National Defense
for example that uh it became a big
problem from an Optics perspective at
least when you had John McCain and Amy
kachar going to Ukraine and hanging out
with these guys and giving them
weapons and training and logistical
support
uh and that the uh Obama administration
have to had to actually go back on and
and specifically carve out a claws that
uh would would uh dictate that none of
the weapons that we were given to
Ukraine would go to the azov uh the the
aav
Brigade because they were Nazis or are
Nazis so okay I mean we've we've
thoroughly I feel debunked this thing
but there are people on the right with
really freshh perspectives on this um
for example example Tim P who always has
the best Insight let's see what he has
to think say about this let's break it
down for you because we do here's from
the Washington pause wait go back up
please I'm sorry this is so dumb but no
no go a little bit further Tim Po's
Temple's ads are awesome do you support
our Second Amendment yes yes no the no
one so small they make the no one so
small yeah oh I misclicked oh no oh no
misclicked I'm gay now it's like well he
does he supports everyone having nukes
even so right yeah um for you because we
do here's from the Washington Free Free
Beacon oh you're going to complain about
this News Guard certified Hunter Biden
called DC to get Ukraine prosecutor
fired for barisma his ex- business
partner reportedly testified he did not
which makes no sense no he did not
testify that he did not this is a this
is tell the with the you support Second
Amendment well the funny thing is I
freebeacon.com so easy to debunk this
article was from August 1st the
transcript of the testimony that he's
talking about was released on August 3rd
two days later and so we didn't know
this this article is talking about
speculation then it came out and the
testimony directly contradicted
everything Tim is saying that's that was
the The Smoking Gun on the Devon Archer
testimony turned out to be a massive
uh nothing Burger which was why
this was being conducted behind closed
doors to begin with because if they had
evidence you think the
Republicans would not have wanted to
televise this trial on Fox News every
goddamn day of course they would the the
investigation was so bad like that it
didn't yield the results that they
wanted to to get out of it so much so
that like the Republicans on the
committee stopped going to the
meetings where they were just like yeah
this sucks like there's nothing going on
here um but of course they still gave at
least enough information for Fox News
and Kaye MC and all these other people
to like run with and and claim was uh
was was a you know real uh accusations
and and and hard evidence of of
misconduct D they really both roll
around in aviator glasses together
that's kind of wild yeah I mean it's
badass you know it's Badass come on get
in son we're going to smoke crack get in
son we're going to go we're get in we're
going to we're fire Victor Shen 2015 to
get Ukrainian prosecutor investigating
his employer fired Archer who set on the
board of Ukrainian gas company Baris
literally reading freebeacon.com right
now but it says look look it's news
certified click on this click on this
click on this click on what
okay Fox News reported oh you can't
God I think I linked to it
though um in the doc let's see if you
can let's see if you can find What the
Fox News Report was saying which again
was from before but look look look arer
also testified Biden called his father
more than 20 times during s the Biden
brand that part is real
here's the article he's reading from but
we'll go down to Fox News Report yeah a
sa told A source told Fox
News Hunter Biden barisma execs called
DC to get Ukrainian prosecutor fired
right so ju SCE told them
this a source go down
yeah I think I looked for I don't if I
told you the story I told you what he
did and it's exactly what I said M
because Deon Archer was directly asked
do you
believe that like Hunter Biden had any
phone conversation with Joe
Biden uh that that would be like
incriminating damaging or was like
genuinely trying to change Biden's
perspective on uh his affairs with bisma
and he said no straight up he's like no
he did
not
oops oh yeah see the White House
president said he was never in business
with his son Archer's testimony ALS also
openly confirmed that as
well you're reading here pres the house
of Republicans own much hyped witness
today testified that he never heard of
President Biden discussing business with
his son or his son's Associates or doing
anything wrong and their much hyped
witness testimony House Republicans keep
promising bombshell evidence to support
the ridiculous attacks against the
president but time after time they keep
failing to produce
any if they had the bombshell evidence
they would have televised this on Fox
News constantly cut videos about like
dein Archer openly stating yeah Hunter
Biden and and Joe Biden are corrupt so
the one little Nifty rhetorical trick
that a lot of the Republicans in
positions of power and also Fox News is
engaging in is notice every time they
talk about this situation under the
impeachment right they always say the
Biden family why are they not saying Joe
Biden why why have they why do they
never mention Joe Biden directly by name
and and how he is related to the hunter
Biden uh misdeeds because that
connection is alleged they've made it up
in their minds which is why instead of
saying like um look at the the amount of
money that uh the Biden family got from
bisma and substitute the Biden family
for Hunter Biden because all of that
other stuff is only done by Hunter Biden
there is at this moment and maybe there
will be new evidence somehow somewhere
down the line but at this moment as far
as all of the investigations that have
been done on the matter there is no
tangible conclusive evidence whatsoever
that connects Hunter Biden and his Mis
dealings with burisma and any other
foreign National with Joe
Brandon
himself here's Tim having a meltdown
when people are saying even his own fans
are saying the case is light he's not
hearing it
primers in their headlines long shot the
fight it's ready for how Donald's doj
gave Biden a major assist in the coming
impeachment probe you
see here's what there there's very few
oh here we go opinion where is the
evidence speaker McCarthy David French
see people like David French are lying
on purpose like there's no way you spend
this much time in in politics and not
know there's a certain patter to that is
pretty so first of all the New York
Times does lie regularly especially on
the opet side I mean they literally sold
the Iraq War those cretans but it is
pretty funny to say like these guys are
lying on purpose like people like David
prch are lying on purpose right after
you pulled up a Washington Free Beacon
article that you defended that literally
was just false okay well guess what he's
got another article to pull up okay
let's see hold on yeah blah blah blah
blah blah where's the evidence where's
the evidence where's the oh no oh no I
stumbled upon evidence what do we do
David David what do I do do I pretend
like the evidence doesn't exist uh this
article reads Hunter Biden called DC to
get Ukraine prose foris his
ex testifies oh no oh David David what
do we do now that there's actual
evidence published in the Washington
Free Beacon oh man uh uh what's this uh
oh it's the New York time
the New York Times what do they say they
say um he's really un Mr Biden confided
to his inner circle that he believed
Trump was a threat to democracy and
should be prosecuted all and and Garland
said he wanted Mr Garland to act less
like a ponderous judge to take more as
act more like a prosecutor who is
willing to take decisive action oh no
what what do we do we have evidence that
Joe Biden flew to Ukraine to get a
prosecutor fired because the prosecutor
was investigating his son's company oh
no wait is it proof what is is he is all
over the place this flew to Ukraine no
Biden Biden did so Biden did actually
pressure the Ukrainian government that
part is true okay he did he wanted
Victor shoken to be fired right but
Victor was Victor shoken was holding up
investigations Victor to barisma
yeah Victor was burisma's Guy Joe firing
him was against their interest yes so I
don't I don't fully understand is it's
like I mean Victor shoken is is anyone's
guy right like whoever is greasing his
pockets uh whoever's greasing him harder
Victor is going to be on board with but
that in of itself represented a threat
for at least foreign Capital with
interest in Ukraine okay I need people
to understand this Ukraine much like
many of the uh former uh Soviet uh
Eastern block countries was robbed of
its resources and and uh was propped up
with a corrupt kleptocracy just like
every other country because of Western
influence in the aftermath of the USSR
falling apart okay so every single
person that is in a position of power in
all of these countries often times are
corrupt just like American politicians
are corrupt these guys are also very
corrupt okay so and this even goes all
the way to uh zilinski as well which uh
many people used to cover like the uh
you know organizations like NATO Prato
organizations and and Outlets would also
talk about zalinski offshoring uh some
of his wealth and yada yada yada none of
that matters at this point what matters
is Victor shoken was not as much in the
western sphere of influence as uh the
the the Western operators in Ukraine
wanted that's it that's why they wanted
him fired okay he he towed the line a
little too much a little too close to
the to the Russian Allegiance
in the Russian sphere of influence and
that's why they that he represented a
threat for people with material interest
in Ukraine that's it so any conversation
beyond that is is so silly to me because
he was already acting in uh at the beest
of
burisma Hunter Biden indicted on Federal
Gun there's actually some breaking news
this happened uh during the show today
so this was part of uh he had like had
that plea deal that fell apart and now
they're charging him with like the gun
stuff I guess which is whatever go for
it you know what I mean it I mean
free my boy Hunter for sure but I mean
listen if he's you know I'm not I'm not
here riding for I don't care about
Hunter Biden you know I don't I
don't take take him please he'll proba
he'll probably get access he'll probably
be having the time of his life in jail
smoking
crack they get they smoke a crack into
prison probably I'm sorry there's
nothing more hilarious and the fact that
like this uh this I smoke crack once you
did yeah did you like it um I didn't I
didn't feel it that's crazy that's the
guy I too weak for my natural uh
existence is crack I don't feel that
it's actually one it's
12:30 yeah uh and we only talked about
one topic we so what do we do
about just say them just say the other
topics but so we just do Biden and
that's the what are we going to do what
are we going to do and uh Starfield
review Starfield review Biden
impeachment Mexican border
harassment right we covered a lot of
politics I mean we even did uh uh we
even did the the uh subber its favorite
topic um Hassan is a tanky who loves
China and Russia see I don't know all
this stuff I was just curious yeah well
I mean it's good I I love just say what
you think if people are going to be away
then they'll be away yeah no I I I
always confronts Assan please not please
don't do that well that's no no no
that's definitely going to happen
regardless well I don't want that to be
the title people should be able to I
mean that is going to be the title
people should be able to uh these
discussions on foreign policy without
like you know being at each other's
throats I think it's kind of weird
especially because at the end of the day
regardless of what my opinion is or what
your opinion is whatever the American
foreign policy apparatus has interest in
a specific country is what is going to
happen so we are in favor of all people
of the world being free yeah me too damn
dude
Freedom Brave to
life and Justice brave brave and true
Freedom reign supreme under god let's
spread it baby yeah spread that our
Christian God I'm spreading Freedom like
them
cheeks like Jo like John Kennedy is
spreading them
cheeks spread hey Cheryl spread those
cheeks why no I me the other Kennedy but
but I want to know what Larry David has
those cheeks why it open for me like
like I do with I like my the brain
barrier spread your cheeks open like the
brain barrier does from the co shot or
no that was from Wi-Fi uh the blood
brain barrier right wi yeah like pen
yeah something like that yo dude we got
to protect our blood brain
barrier you know I'm saying all right we
got to go though um oh no is this real
dude he doesn't look very happy to be I
I'll say Larry does not seem happy to be
there I think he was doing a little
goofy face though like he would do
either way um I I I and this is a old
photo is this from their wedding or
something from their wedding okay so
then he didn't he wasn't as big
as a ant for C back then you
know what I mean yeah was just co-star
at the time yeah yeah Larry's the best
man you know he's vaxed up Larry's vaxed
the up he seems like the kind of
guy that would that would get extra
vaxed he's like got that shirtless Eddie
yeah he'd go around to clinics and shots
get like eight Co line them
up um all right guys so thank you Hanan
thank you very much thank you all once
again there's a uh flash sale happening
on Teddy fresh.com go check it out it's
all happening right now
fan uh sorry about Mexico they really
got you huh
Bud yeah Hassan now understands why
taxation is theft yeah I'm I'm I'm
already a capitalist I've already been a
capitalist you know and I'm I'm
simultaneously a capitalist and also a
tanky who defends uh Russia and CH
that's right wait Mexican uh Border
Patrol was like give me
$200 ugly you disgusting literally is
what they give $200 what they said all
right guys we'll be back tomorrow for
after dark it's going to be a fun fun
show laughs Goofs everything in between
it's all happening ass have a fantastic
weekend thanks for being here nice to
see
you going to be much better classic no
offense yeah no no taking I
agree all right take care guys see you
[Music]
then